*blinks in morse code*
I was just communicating with you through
eye blinking morse code. What did I say?
You're a pervert.
Hi my Name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know now you know your life Is different now
*sigh* man I've Been Making YouTube Videos for
Oh No
Math Ummm
Almost 10 Years?
Almost 10 Years. and I Gotta Be Honest
It's tiring and sometimes makes me mentally very burnt out
and I started thinking about other professions that I might do if I wasn't doing YouTube
And I realized, I wouldn't be good at those so i thought let's turn this Into a series called
"Why I can't be dot dot dot" and this Inaugural Episode is "why I can't be a teacher"
I can't remember names
Okay, who has the answer to Today's Question
Yes Potato... it's Patricia
Well you Look like a Potato
I'm genuinely not a good influence on youth in an unedited environment
No...
what... no...
but we can't see our books in the dark... oh shut the fuck up Crystal...
are you hungover Miss Helbig?... suck One Thousand Dicks Potato...
I'm actually potato but it's Patri-
I'm of British descent so i'm very repressed emotionally which means I have a hard time communicating any type of concern
excuse me miss Helbig, um do you think I might be able to get a letter of recommendation from you?
P... okay, no to Stanford... what... I'm Applying to Stanford University
You are?... I am... yes I get it all very good letters but you're applying to Stanford?... yeah
Is there something wrong with that
no... I feel like you're lying... I feel like you should suck a thousand dicks... what?
also, I run away from conflict. Lastly and most Importantly
I'm not good at explaining complex subject matter in a simplified way
so as you can see E equals MC-Squared
Any follow-up questions?
yes p- t- tato
but what does that mean?
uhh..  well I think it's pretty obvious
um
e Equals
mc squared
You just turned the equation into a dick...
YEAH, well you can suck a thousand of em Potato
-- Patricia
Eat a - eat a dick,  eat all, eat dick
There you go! there are just a few reasons why I can't be a teacher
Let me know if you agree or disagree
Don't forget to click subscribe, I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
Sometimes
and click that little bell notification so that you know when I make videos
because I don't... uhhh
I don't do it regularly
sooo at your own convenience it's better to have that bell notification turned on so you're alerted
so you don't have to wait up for hours and hours because I know you all desperately wait for my video uploads
other than that thank you for watching, I don't know
*vibrator clinks*